Brandon backflow used to be the
assistant to the original stylist who
was with gaga and involved with her and
did the meat dress and all the latex and
all four early looks but then as Brandon
transitioning becoming her full-time
stylist all that old Hollywood all the
Tony Bennett all of that you're seeing
that's Brandon they are best friends I
mean if they you have someone who sees
you naked that much every single day
yeah you have a close relationship
Brandon helped to fashion Gaga's Marc
Jacobs style on stage and all the red
carpet so here's the story behind the
Gaga dress and the Bowie looks so once
the sketches and the concept was
approved by Lady Gaga herself in New
York that's when it all started
the dress was done it was shipped to
Paris to the best Couture salons in the
world where embellishment and feathers
and everything was put on it then it was
shipped back to New York for finishing
touches and then on a plane for final
fittings in Los Angeles and I have to
say they were literally sewing and
fitting hours before the Grammys next
question is what will Gaga wear to the
Oscars
one look at Brandon's New York Fashion
Week show gives us a clue lots of
strapless flared structures fallow the
hips all modern and chic do you believe
that I'm a different author that's like
12 days away I don't know you know I
think you know she's a legend I think
she will be there she's popping in
during Entertainment Tonight